how's
it going guys it's time to address a
comment
this was one about advice for starting a
new job three things
i've learned so let's just take a look
okay so on this video maybe saw it maybe
didn't
i don't know watch it if you want it's
just some advice
advice for starting a new job and
someone left a comment
and it's here so i just want to respond
because i kind of said i would
so uh here we go i'll read the comment
first so
i can do this in the most legit
way possible all right it says can you
make a video on looking for a job in the
tech field slash
motivation for programming i lost my job
around a year ago during the peak of the
virus and have no motivation to look for
one
or work on personal projects to improve
my skills
being let go without any notice left a
bad taste in my mouth it still lingers
today
do you know what might be the best thing
for me just lost and felt like
lamenting even my friends who are very
talented can't find a job
and then thanks for the tutorials
learned quite a bit
awesome the last part not so awesome
on this part and
well i've thought about this some
and i think it's a very common scenario
that uh it really sucks basically
it's a really crappy scenario
all right well i uh i'm just gonna riff
on this
i kind of like made one video already
but i wasn't really happy with it i
don't think my advice was
good enough or helpful enough so i've
been writing a few things down here and
there
about what might help
but what it comes down to is
i don't know and nobody
does but here's the thing about that
about me not knowing and nobody know it
some people will tell you they know some
people will say
i know what's best for you and then give
you some thing to do
or some method to follow and
the problem with that is well
they're not you so they're wrong it is
something
you have to come to some kind of
conclusion yourself and
listening to other people's advice and
listening to other people's talks
and listen to other people's methods
might help but ultimately it's got to be
some conclusion you come to yourself
and that goes for everyone and that's
it's true for me too
i want to be a little bit honest and raw
here with you guys
i've been in a funk for like a while too
it hasn't been it hasn't been
going as well as i would have hoped will
say but it's been going fine
my channel's still growing slowly but
surely
it's uh really hard to get uh
patrons on the patreon page so i don't
know what to do
with that occasionally really get a new
one but
it's then occasionally i'll lose one so
i don't know i have no idea to be honest
i've been trying to figure out what to
do and i'm going to do some things
i've got some kind of little plans that
i'm going to try on
but that's just one thing you know
and i don't know if that's relevant or
not but
all right i'll get to my list because
i'm kind of just rambling at this point
but i guess what i'm trying to say
is i don't feel like the type of person
or i don't feel like the person that's
in
a way right now that i should be giving
this sort of advice
yeah and that's not entirely true
because uh there's some things like
i know that if i wanted to go get
whatever job i wanted i could probably
do it
i i feel i have that confidence but
here's also the thing
you might see a job that you think okay
if i could get this when i would do it
and you apply and you do your best and
you think this is the one i'm gonna get
it and it doesn't happen
someone else gets selected and then what
it's happened to me i've seen jobs and i
thought hey i really would like to do
this
so i put my best foot forward and i
didn't get it but
i usually ended up getting something
else that was
fine and maybe even better or
you know that sort of thing happens so
you you can't plan
everything you can't guarantee anything
it's sort of like trying to bet on the
stock market you're gonna win some
you're gonna lose up and you can't
really predict it
no matter what signs you see no matter
how much gamestop should be going down
it's still going up
you know that's just an example but
there's so many different little little
nuggets out there
that can kind of hit home but ultimately
it doesn't
matter how much they hit home if they
don't
you know make the action come out
or make you change your mind or make the
switch flip
all right to the list so
these are pretty random pretty random
orders so i'm just going to kind of riff
on what i got here
so the first thing i wrote on this list
is the wide
variety of advice online is wrong
and i kind of already covered that with
you know everybody's just got to make
their own decision about these things
so you lost the motivation to program
well here's the first things i think of
when i want motivation to program i need
a goal
and the goal needs to have a purpose and
i haven't really had that recently
i really really want to make a game but
when i fire up on real engine
or unity or a godot i can't stand the
way these programs are made
i don't like them i'm not a big fan of
unreal not a big fan of unity
they feel annoying i feel like i can't
make the game i wanted them
without some abnormally
high amount of hours put into it i feel
like it should be way easier to do what
i'm trying to do
that's why i'm making my own game engine
it gives me some motivation
to just work on my own game engine which
is also very hard because there's so
much to figure out
and it's just me like i have to figure
out all these shaders have to figure out
all the pvr
stuff i have to figure out all the
animations i have to figure out how to
organize all the code
all this c and c plus plus code
in a way that makes sense and it's way
too much for one person
but i'm doing it anyway and i'm still
trying to do it
and i'm i don't know i put up an ad to
try to hire someone to help work on the
shaders but
zero people have applied so i don't know
maybe it's not getting the visibility
maybe not enough people know
there's all these things that it could
be but what it comes down to
is i'm not trying very hard
so i have to ask myself
why and that's why you should be asking
yourself too
why why have you lost motivation
programming was it because
you lost your job or is it because
you don't have a solid goal in mind
i remember a couple years ago i guess
it's been about three years now
i programmed non-stop i can't do that
anymore
the reason i programmed non-stop is
because
i had a very direct goal in mind and i
wanted to see it through
so i would just work on this thing all
day
and another thing that helped i don't
know if this is relevant or not but
i had less distractions i wasn't playing
video games i was actually
stuck in a really boring job and what
was more fun than my really boring job
was programming so when all the down
time i would program as soon as i get a
break i would program
it was way better than my actual job but
now
that i've been just kind of mostly
sitting at home
there's a lot more fun things to do i go
do whatever i want
so with all those options coding is not
exactly at the top of the list of fun
things that are available
so maybe that's relevant maybe you're
too distracted
all right
i wrote down a lot of these philosophies
that i come across online
like the stoic philosophy or sometimes
it's called
something along the lines of the red
pill uh they're kind of intertwined a
little bit although they're different
and i'm not an expert in these i just
kind of see them and you know do some
investigations
watch some things but those will just
tell you to kind of suck it up and
go apply for jobs and go get one
and maybe that's the answer for some
people but i don't feel like that's a
very good answer
so there's probably things you can do
to make little steps in the right
direction like you start working out
every day
or at least a little a day or start
eating better maybe your
mind will start critically thinking a
little bit better and you can figure out
these things that are bothering you and
find some motivation
not sure you know that some like i said
ultimately but all of this something you
have to decide
there's nobody that's gonna tell you the
perfect advice if you're
searching around hunting around for the
perfect advice waiting for the perfect
advice to come your way
it never will you'll grow old you'll
miss out on all kinds of stuff
and your life will be over because
that's the reality of things
so i don't know what you gotta do
but you gotta do it and that's that's
what gets me going
some days i think
where's the time going you know and i
have to metaphorically slap myself back
into reality
like why why am i just wasting a whole
day i've got to get something done
you know
there's a lot of psychiatry type stuff
you could listen to
like dr k the healthy gamer guy he does
a lot of interviews with people that
have
a wide variety of problems maybe some of
that will help
sometimes i find those help me certain
ones anyway
so they're pretty interesting i've
learned a lot from from him and i know a
lot of people online do maybe you
already have
so maybe that's useful advice there's a
lot of stuff
from jordan peterson in his lectures
some of that's okay
i don't i don't agree with all of it but
it seems to help some people and it
actually helped me a lot when i was
going through college
because it kind of it lit the fire
for me to to not give up in a lot of
occasions because i wanted to give up at
times
and you know i didn't
and sometimes when i some days when i
just had no motivation
and i felt like giving up i would just
put on one of his videos
and he would you know just hearing him
kind of gave me the the harsh reality of
i gotta be responsible you know you
gotta be responsible
no matter who you are there's someone
out there counting on you
you said your even your friends who are
very talented can't find a job
well maybe if you can find a way to do
it
that'll somehow inspire them and they'll
find a way to do it and suddenly
everyone's
figuring stuff out and moving along just
because you did
so i it's interesting how you can be an
inspiration almost accidentally
sometimes
just by you know just
power and through and i have a lot more
to say on that
but i'll i'll keep it brief and just say
that's kind of what i've done you know i
have a lot of
friends from back in the day that
didn't really go anywhere you know they
they went kind of down a dark path and
well i tried not to
i tried to advance to get better to move
forward
to follow the dreams that i had
and maybe i might not be there yet but
i'm still i'm still working on it
and i think they see that now
i know one of them i saw him post
something recently
he's finally getting over some of these
bad habits
who knows it's social media that i'm
seeing this on so you never know if it's
fake or what but
i part of me thinks that maybe
maybe he's saul that i was and thought
like
he could do it too so you could be that
person or you could
see someone else like that that could do
it but i don't want to say it was all me
because
there were people i saw that were doing
that sort of thing that definitely
helped me
too i don't know if that makes sense but
it's just kind of an observation
there's another thing i saw online
um this guy named simon cynic he
gives a bunch of speeches about
corporate stuff and
he has this video on trust and
performance
and it's all about the people who become
leaders
or the trustworthy ones i think he said
that
people who should become leaders are the
trustworthy ones
so uh and what
tends to happen is the ones that have
the best performance become leaders but
the ones that have the best performance
are not necessarily the most trustworthy
or the best leaders
something along those lines so i think
the point is here
i guess if you want to be a leader or
move forward or grow
is you just need to be honest it doesn't
necessarily matter how performant you
are
although it matters so i'm sure but it's
more about
being trustworthy
so if anything just just be honest
mostly with yourself
but with everyone around you and given
that you've already you know kind of
left this comment i think you're
probably coming to terms with things
that are probably on your way
upward
all right there's uh there's another
thing i don't know where this originated
from but
it's the backwards law
and it's how things kind of happen the
opposite of what you
expect or the opposite of what you're
trying to do
like if you're searching for happiness
you're probably going to be sad
if you're lamenting and feeling
terrible and just letting all the rage
out you're probably going to feel good
it's it's this backwards thing where
you almost have to just kind of stop
searching and just
kind of go with it whatever you feel go
with it
it's uh it's it's weird i'm not sure how
to fully explain it
someone might be able to do it better
but
there's an interesting thing there where
people that are always
trying to act positive or be positive
are often quite sad
and the ones who are bitter or cranky
are usually actually pretty happy
so i don't it's something i've kind of
noticed too
not always true and i might not be
explaining that very well
but another thing i've learned recently
i don't know why i'm wearing these
headphones it's not like i'm listening
to anything
oh well um
don't let people affect you now this is
one that i've had to learn
over the last few years especially doing
youtube
is you just simply can't let people
affect you there's a lot of people that
are going to try to tell you things
like for me for example you can just
like not listen to me at all
just who cares who cares what i say
doesn't matter
you can do that with anyone and anything
there's no particular reason why you
need to let people affect you
and i wish that some people would learn
this when you're young but when you're
young
people affect you very strongly when you
get older
people stop affecting you so much so
maybe you're young
and this is one of your first jobs and
you had a really bad experience
and you don't know about this trick of
just not letting that that
company affect you there's no reason to
bring
baggage into a new job or a new place or
forward in your life
there really just isn't it's kind of
pointless
you you just learn from it and move on
there's a lot to say on that but
okay here's another one there's this uh
there's this guy seth goat
goden seth godin he talks a lot about
um being creative and finding your
creative space
and uh he has a lot of interesting
advice but one of the things he says
that really hit home for me
was basically to ignore criticism as you
might know i get a lot of criticism if i
go look at my old videos
some of them are like 50 down votes
or maybe even a quarter down votes only
80
positive likes you know and that kind of
hurts to see
but i was a long time ago
and i already know i can do better and
there's a lot more to it but basically i
just have to ignore all that criticism
because people still leave comments from
videos like three years ago like
about what i could do better on that
video and i'm like
geez man you're really
really beating that dead horse so like
what am i supposed to do about that
nothing i just have to ignore it so
there's just a lot of comments i get
every day that well not every day
okay i i should say the vast majority of
comments i get are positive
they're thanks for helping thanks for
the tutorial stuff like that and i
really appreciate that that's really
heartwarming
so those are the ones i think of when
i think should i continue my channel or
should i do something else
i always think of all these positive
comments and those are the ones that
drive me forward if i only thought of
all the critical ones
i would wait i would probably actually
just go jump off a cliff
if i thought of only the critical
comments because some of them are pretty
mean
but i i like to do is laugh at them
maybe i'll make a video on all the mean
comments because
they are quite funny i there's some
there was one i can't remember what it
said exactly but
it was something about it was on the
monitor unboxing
someone left a comment like uh
i was like this is so boring it's like
watching my mom set up a
monitor or something and every time i
read that comment i bust out laughing it
just is the funniest comment
because i can see my mom trying to set
up a monitor and it would be painful
incredibly painful so like even these
negative comments are sometimes
like good in a way so
yeah just ignore criticism that isn't
helpful
all right here's a few more things
listen to the people that actually get
it you know a lot of people are going to
try to get give you advice that do not
know your situation
or what you're trying to do so when you
do have like a close friend that's kind
of in the same boat with you
that's the person whose advice maybe you
should consider
a few other things i don't know if this
is entirely relevant but i wrote it down
so i'll say it alright
and it's from the same same guy it was
okay this was seth godin on the jordan
harbinger podcast so that's the source
um
said it kind of came up that everybody
has deep insecurity like me right now
making this video
i have no idea if this is going to be
helpful i'm a bit insecure about it but
do i care
well it's not the right way to word it
it's just like a
i'm going to do it anyway that's that's
basically how i've released
videos so much you know you see some
there's a lot of people i know i've
known a lot of these people i've known
tons of them there are so many of them
in fact it's nearly everyone in my
local world i'm surrounded with nearly
every single person
a hundred percent of them would love to
do what i'm doing
but none of them do it i'm the only one
i don't know a single other person
making youtube videos
although all of them say they would like
to
but why can't they i'm literally just
turning on a camera and answering a
comment and going through some things
and then people are inspired by this
so i guess my advice is you know it's
like
i don't want to say just do it because
that's so obvious but
you got to get over the fear i guess
somehow
i don't i don't know the answer i'm kind
of probably a special case because
i kind of don't have fear which i know
sounds crazy
but that's that's how i get through life
that's how i advance
things don't frighten me things i don't
get star struck
i can meet famous people and i don't
really care and i'll talk normal to them
or i'll treat them like anybody else
and it's it hasn't always been like that
but
so at some point in my life that like
clicked i think it was in my early
twenties where
i don't know something something kind of
clicked or changed for me where
i kind of realized that life is just
like this
this one time thing and there's no
reason to
like overblow things that are just other
people living like who cares it's just
other people living that's what i'm
doing
so so why do you want me to be all goo
gaga about you when we're just in the
same boat you know so
maybe that's something that'll help
because that that's kind of my mentality
is uh i literally don't get why people
are special
i don't get why pewdiepie special i
don't get why mr beast special you know
all these big youtubers
i don't get what's special about them
other than they hire people to edit
their videos
i guess i could hire people to edit my
videos maybe that would make me special
i don't know but you know you can take
that going forward
because say
you'll have to adapt this in your own
way but if you want motivation
you can find it in that because you know
a lot of people
stop at oh i'm going to be criticized or
people are going to think i'm stupid
or whatever that's fine with me i'm fine
with people thinking i'm stupid it
doesn't bother me
like it's always going to happen
you can be the smartest person in the
world you can make the
the most brilliant discoveries in the
world and people are still going to
think you're stupid
there's no stopping it there's no
getting around it you might as well just
push on
you might as well just do what you want
to do anyway
you might as well just do what you want
to do
i live by that i really do
all right let's see what else we got ah
there's this book
called the subtle art of not giving an f
and i'm not gonna say it on my channel
because i don't want to get
ads taken off you know i need everyone i
can get at this point i'm struggling
here
to you know make it month to month so
yeah the subtle art of not giving enough
look it up there's audio books of it
online
there's summaries of it
it's it's it's helped me i guess you
know i listen to it and
it's kind of already my mentality so
it's kind of like ready
iterating what i already knew but it's
very interesting to see it
said so blatantly with so many examples
i couldn't read the whole book it was
it was a bit long it was kind of
repetitive after a while because
like literally the title says the book
so how much can you really read before
you're like alright it's just the same
thing over and over
but that's what i got
let me see is there anything else
yeah that's it so
stop listening to people stop caring
just go do it go do what you want you
know
this is your life forget everyone else
it doesn't matter if uh someone's more
successful or less successful
oh geez i'm really going on like a
nihilistic rampage now i i don't want to
go i don't want to do that but
you probably got an idea of how i keep
going and
maybe some ideas of how you can keep
going because ultimately it doesn't
matter what i do or what i say
maybe it'll help you a little maybe you
can take something from this
but i've never heard one single like
you know like one thing that was like
all right that's it
now i've got what i need i'm moving
forward that's never happened it's
always been like
just taking in lots of different things
and coming up with my own conclusions
so i imagine that's probably what you
got to do too
all right well keep working on things
keep coding keep
slamming away at those problems and uh
geez i want to cuss so bad but i'm not
going to do it i'm not going to risk it
because you know that this is like the
situation where you just want to say
you know effort kind of thing and that's
what it is
i wouldn't advise that you know going
into you know it's still the same for
going into a job
you gotta look professional you gotta be
professional you gotta show them that
you care
about the position and all that stuff
that's pretty normal it's pretty
standard
but it's it's really important to
realize that everyone's about the same
we're all human we're all we're all
struggling with
with life and going through life and we
all have our ups and downs
and no one expects you to be perfect
because everybody knows
everybody knows deep down inside
we've all got some kind of thing we're
working through
and we just don't need
the the crap of everybody
being down on each other for for no
particular reason
that's kind of one thing i learned too
is if someone doesn't treat you well
you should judge them very harshly and
you should probably rail them
that's one thing i learned that that has
improved my life a ton
i i stopped taking people's
negativity or terrible treatment like me
i don't know when it happened but you
know there's always some instance in
your life where someone's kind of you
know
not treating you right or you can tell
they don't like you or something like
that
don't accept that come back adam
say something no matter who it is
doesn't matter how famous they are or
impressive they are
or how much further ahead they are or
how much better at whatever it is
that they are still not acceptable
i'll leave you with one last story here
because it just popped into my head and
it's kind of relevant and was that
my first programming job it was a really
cool job
i had a lot of really important duties
and we were working on this uh
this paper for
well it was for long story short it was
for this protein
research thing and i was helping with
the programming and its algorithm and
getting the program up and running that
did his thing and uh the main
person who was like you know the leader
of the lab the owner of the lab
the big the head honcho
he was he was not nice to anybody in his
lap he was very kind of like cranky and
annoying and mean and cruel to like
everybody in his lap
and he didn't show that at first but
after i was in the lab for a while and
working on this stuff
i started i started to see it i would
see him do it to other people
i would hear stories of what happened in
the past hear stories about people that
quit because i couldn't stand him
and uh then one day he tried to do it to
me
and you know what happened i'll let him
have it
um first of all i raised my voice just
just a little bit and i told him how it
was
and he didn't know what to do i could
give you the exact story but it's not
really
that relevant i guess now okay i'll try
to
i'll try to paraphrase so i don't
remember it like 100 but basically
i had to give a presentation for a
meeting so i was given a presentation
and there was a bunch of
i don't i was just presenting my the
stuff i was doing for the program
basically
but he was like on this kick where he
suddenly
apparently wanted me to know everything
about biology because it was asking me
questions that i had
no idea what the answer was like like
what is the beginning of a protein i'm
like
i don't know what you tell me
i'm just over here trying to get this
program to work right that you
sort of wrote um which i did
and it was great so
but he did in a very mean way he was
like very cranky about it
and i just i was just honest with him i
was just
but i came back at him like look why
would i know this stuff
like i'm trying to study this stuff but
it's not my main field of study
if you want to ask me specific details
about biology of course i'm not going to
know them if you want
me to know specific things you're going
to have to tell me because i'm not going
to study every little thing
i said something like that back to him
like in front of everybody while i was
presenting
in front of all his peers and everybody
just got silent and i just kind of
stared him down
and that was it i moved on
then like i just went on with my
presentation like nothing happened
basically
and he was like he just stopped he just
kind of shut up you know
and uh later on i wrote him a letter and
i said
i'll be leaving the lab in one month and
i told him where i was going what i was
doing you know very
you know as professional as i could but
deep down
i knew that i was like yeah sure if this
was a great job and and great peers and
everything
i probably would have stayed but given
these few incidents and all these things
i heard it's like i'm not going to treat
anybody any worse but i'm also
you know i was still trying to be kind
everybody but if someone's gonna
do something like that to me up why i'm
presenting
heck no i'm not gonna take it you know
people wouldn't normally do that this
guy this guy was a special case he was
he was kind of a mean weirdo you know in
that way i hope he doesn't watch this
video
because they don't have to address this
or maybe it'll make him really sad i
don't know or maybe it'll kick him in
the gear
and he'll stop doing that to people
because it's it's pretty ridiculous to
have to work with someone like that but
it didn't bother me you know i went got
another job it was way better
and paid a whole lot more and everybody
was way cooler
so i'm glad i left it was the right
choice
also there was a thing that happened
after i left
okay i'm extending the story a little
bonus for you guys i guess
where i was working already working at
the new job and it was awesome it was
going good
but he he was like hey i need you to
come back and finish this one last thing
for the paper
i don't know how to do it i just need it
was like getting docker running and
get this whole thing running docker
basically and i was like sure i can i
can do it i know how to use docker
it's not a big deal i was like all right
so so what's the plan like uh when you
want me to work on this what's the
compensation
and he was like oh no no no compensation
uh we're you just need to come in and
finish it because
because your name's on the paper you
know so and i was like no that's
that's not how it's going to work look
i'm already working 40 hours a week
plus commuting plus i have a family i'm
not just going to spend a bunch of extra
time
working on this thing for you and so i
just
i threw a number at him i was like i
don't know give him pay me
this much and i'll do it and he was like
no
i was like okay so i picked up my bag
and i started to leave and he was like
wait wait wait
and he said i don't know what he said
but he said like oh he tried to like
threaten me
with something and he was like uh
so he was like your name doesn't have to
be on this paper and i just was like
you do whatever you think is right and i
kept walking away i left
and that was it and he did end up
putting my name on the paper
which was the right thing to do
obviously because i worked on it a bunch
but like he literally tried to threaten
me with that so
pretty happy to not be working with that
awful boss again but also
i didn't let it bother me going forward
you know some people are just like that
and it's not your fault
so do you think be yourself
good luck to you whoever you are out
there that man
manages to be watching this and uh yeah
this is unedited so
sorry for maybe the weird blunders are
sent to
sentences that i've made but it is what
it is and
yeah all right i'm out see you guys
it's